welcome to this video playing tactic
who's here Zoltan this is all tonight
med vision yes so let's see what is he
doing here the Slav probably no I
thought you would play the Slav for some
reason I don't have a great score
against this guy two out of seven yes
that sets a line nowadays if they play
the double fianchetto now that's not so
bad or can be played I have no
particular knowledge there but this
looks very natural to play
let's see if i can trade that mmm is d5
a move that's a move i would like to
play here maybe i can prepare it okay he
has no objection objection it seems i
wonder if I five if I can take them on e
595 Bishop g2 95 could be could be cool
Bishop g4 isn't decisions are symbols
when I g-form I think it's possible I'd
mr. tactical sailing tactics or what I
don't know it looks funny it looks
playable maji form
yeah I think it has to probably take on
e5 and then play it porn down but that's
not really a nice position also for
concrete reasons the bishop only force
in the diagonal and the three hundy
seven that doesn't feel very nice but I
don't see how he is taking home ok so we
rather place this position maybe yeah
maybe that's better in comparison can't
scrap him that's just a pawn of course
but maybe better if you compare the two
ok I can give the check their only five
I mean sorry on diesel I mean ok so
guess the night has to go back at one
point anyway yeah i'm just a pawn up but
other than that Black has you can double
on the e-file for example and play with
this this kind of ideas um midnight
there are only three yeah it's not such
a great piece let's protect a 1 and then
regroup the nite nite c2 to divorce what
I want to try to achieve
okay I should get out of this diagonal
yeah so now f3e 494 and then he's all
all backwards
so here and then a three before would be
would be nice
okay ch.5 that's not leading to anywhere
at least I don't see I don't see it so
now night is six would basically force
them to sack the exchange now let's
let's do that night c79 f4 that's too
much check so Knight to e5 is probably
what he wants to do so let's push f for
that also takes away all those pink
squares for the rook a4ai one drug t 5
f-5 is also move but probably work till
five is good maybe you should go a
four-year toronto area trying to at
least them we can make one structure a
bit
if I've is not on I guess take it
Queenie 345 maybe 45 I've got a bit
ahead on the clock that's good yeah I
also wouldn't mind queen dee 5 of course
k so King f2
maybe here on that is 625 Oh gf5 h h 5
sorry i wasn't really expecting that one
ok let's open up the position check
yeah I know maybe its toughest to play
Queenie six down trade Queens and hope
hope to survive I don't know okay so
Queen g7 king of six there no tactic
there to win if I go rookie for where is
he going that's go before
really see no square on a good square
also j have roped XH form if everything
last rays I else failed yeah that was
funnier this 95 tactic but yeah it's
very often all based on 100 unprotected
piece there I think he has to be proven
I mean if I he cannot play and he has to
maybe yes to take here I take with the
pawn that's better than the bishop
because I have this this immediate
roller here and I'm just quicker in this
position he doesn't really get to play
on the on the e-file him yeah if I was
just losing i think in 95 but I did I
probably didn't execute this too well i
can now here i should actually start
maybe with f3 and e4 and then get my
night back quickly I look Chandler's
lots of time there with with all this
stuff but I think I got back on the
right track here this is this is
probably just winning I think yeah 95 is
a funny tactic we can look at some of
the points there yeah here ya are
threatening made yeah so he cannot just
check oops cannot just do this that's
made and yeah what what else if he goes
um if he goes um yeah let's say f5 yeah
I have Queen D for check and night h6
check and then I will take that so it's
a it's always a wind it's really really
a really a funny tactic okay well thanks
for watching